mais 46 ans je suis est marié et père de
quatre enfants est donc je suis affecté
au commissariat de sécurité publique
d'elancourt dans les yvelines qu'est ce
qui fait moins de chrétiens aujourd'hui
c'est rencontre personnelle avec jésus
avec sa parole et qu'elle négocie pas
est ce que finalement c'était une
profession de compatible avec l'évangile
ça a été un sujet problématique et j'ai
mis quelques petites années à vraiment
faire le point de vue j'ai été aidé en
cela par des chrétiens qui sont aussi
policiers qui m'ont fait partager les
perles de l'évangile et de la parole de
dieu qui qui fixe un peu en six ans
cette profession notamment je pense
aussi un verset qui me vient là comme ça
de les soldats romains qui vont voir
saint jean baptiste et qui lui demande
qu'est ce que nous devons faire pour
hériter du royaume de dieu nous aussi et
saint-jean-baptiste il aurait pu leur
dire changer de métier ou venez à ma
société tous et non non il aura vivre
contentez-vous de l'autre soldes et ne
fait de tort à personne
rien de spécial
bon j'ai passé une autre pour nous que
de la route c'est pareil c'est
tranquille ce matin le nom du service et
la brigade accidents et délits routiers
enfin voilà pour donc c'est
essentiellement une activité de
traitement de procédures de bureau qui
exclut pas en fait des
sorties sur le terrain pour faire des
relevés topographiques ou des ports de
convocation mais c'est vrai que dans mon
service on n'a pas vocation à faire de
la police secours ou affaires delà des
interventions ce qu'on pourrait appeler
de muscler les faits quand j'étais plus
jeune mais c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
cas
j'ai appris à faire la différence entre
l'acte posé et la personne qui pose
l'acte je suis là pour rassembler des
éléments et je suis pas là pour faire
passer mes sentiments quant à l'acte
posé ni pur jus clemi pour même condamné
le côté professionnel est toujours en
essayant de respecter le plus possible
la dignité de la personne et de ne pas
oublier qu'il s'agit d'un être humain
alors non présentation immédiate du
permis de conduire voilà c'est ça il n'a
pas présenté son permis de conduire ma
foi chrétienne ou m'aide pas faire des
amalgames et penser que le coupable il
n'a pas un portrait-robot type le
coupable c'est n'importe lequel d'entre
nous ou d'entre eux et quand on est tous
porteurs de ce bal de cette possibilité
de mal faire ou au contraire de faire et
bien
si la
merci donc celui-là ici je colle le
premier
ici
donne ça ici on il ya dix ans de ça j'ai
eu un problème de santé assez important
donc pour pouvoir me préserver me
reconstruire l'administration aménager
ce poste parce que j'étais interdit de
voie publique à l'époque en raison de
mon état de santé et il se trouve que se
libérer un poste à la brigade accident
qui par définition est un poste plus
sédentaires donc de travail de bureau
c'est comme ça et j'ai intégré ce poste
et c'était le 1er octobre un 1er octobre
2000 ans et le sait dans l'église en
fait la petite thérèse de lisieux ce
jour là et finalement ça à faire onze
ans que j'y suis maintenant donc
voilà et puis j'ai pris mes habitudes et
c'est surtout un travail régulier qui me
permet d'avoir une activité associative
en paroisse donc parce que je travaille
pas le soir est très rarement le
week-end donc c'est vrai que pour un
engagement paroisse c'est quand même
plus plus adaptée relation claire exprès
dans un premier temps pendant cinq ans
il était à l'aumônerie des étudiants de
la paroisse d'elancourt maurepas et
aujourd'hui donc depuis le mois de
janvier je suis à l'aumônerie des gens
de voyage ans donc c'est vrai que les
gens du voyage c'est une population que
le mode sédentaire méprise parfois et la
police un peu plus souvent encore dans
quelle c'est vrai que les gens du voyage
ont le souci aussi comme la majeure
partie des français d'être dans la
société ni plus ni moins qu avec encore
pas systématiser ne pas être sans vie de
travail et de se marier d'avoir des
enfants et de com comme tout le monde en
quoi vous êtes dans les fans lui
ressembler et puis elle prendra la
couleur que je lui donnerai puisque je
peux être partie prenante je suis une
pierre vivante aussi et ça a été la
conscience qu'il eut pris de dire voilà
je fais partie de cette église je suis
membre de de cette église est cheminot
partie une part active de cette église
leur mouvement enfin
alors ce sens et une réunion de prière
donc
la clé saint-pierre conventionnelle pas
le projet c'était d'offrir à la
communauté catholique chrétienne à des
gens de voyage un point aussi 3 je
l'avais nouvelle pour créer une occasion
supplémentaire d'avoir accès à la parole
de dieu est la longe on est sur ce
rendez vous jusqu'à pâques c'était alors
c'est un test pour voir donc monclar
tous les doutes que toutes les semaines
chaque mercredi comme
tout ce qui est associé à la guitare
c'est son côté vagabonde et à
ses côtés artisanat rossi enfin la
faille et plein de et j'ai toujours
trouvé ça sympa et c'est vrai que pour
les seniors j'ai eu à coeur ma
conversion vallée dire cette bonne
nouvelle sans qu'on me le demande mais
c'est pour moi ça a été un peu comme la
samaritaine
laisse sans cela elle court au village
et elle raconte à tout le monde ce qui
lui est arrivé donc c'est vraiment ce
que je voulais faire sans qu'on les
livres j'ai trouvé qu'en tout cas c'est
une bonne approche pour rentrer pour
dépoussiérer un peu la danse démenti
qu'ils ne poussent à crier qu'il me
pousse à tenter
m
ce
mon dieu
c'est un
me pousse à billets qui le pousse à
chanter
le pam m